Stop me if you've heard this one before.
There is only one Quran, one book that
has been revealed by Allah that all the
Muslims around the world memorize word
for word, letter for letter. Well, we're
going to see if that's true.
>> It's
God.
[Music]
You've heard it said by all the dies,
all the popular dwagandas that there's
only one Quran memorized, untouched,
uncorrupted, never to be changed, never
has been changed. You all heard this
before.
>> The Quran has been preserved. We believe
since the time of the prophet till now,
word for word, letter for letter, haraka
or vow sign for vow sign.
>> There has never been two copies of the
Quran that are different even in one
letter or one word.
>> So we believe in that one Quran
memorized letter by letter, word by
word. Well, today I brought up I brought
some friends along with me and we're
going to give you guys five variants.
Five Quran variants that every Christian
should know. You guys should have this
all in your pockets, in your back
pockets whenever you're talking to a
Muslim. Five Quran variants. Easy to
explain, easy to show to your Muslim
friends. And I brought my friends to
talk about this giant DLC. What's up,
guys?
>> Hey, what's up? What's up?
>> Hey.
>> What's up, man? What's up? What up, DLC?
You in there?
>> I'm in there. How are you?
>> Pretty good. All right, guys. So, we got
five Quran variants, easy ones, right?
Uh, now we're not talking about English,
you know, translations that are
different, right? We're talking about
the Arabic in the Arabic, different
versions of the Quran, different variant
readings that aren't just dialect
changes, but are, you know, different
words that change the meaning. Is that
that's what we're talking about, right,
guys?
>> That's exactly right. That's exactly
what we're talking about. We're talking
about differences in the Arabic text,
different versions of the Arabic text.
>> Perfect. All right. So, with that being
said, one of these that come to my mind,
if you guys have been watching the
channel for a long time, you guys are
familiar with this one, but uh we have
uh that comes to my mind is chapter
37:12.
Now, I got my Arabic speakers here so
they could break this down. Now, DLC, do
you mind reading this if you could see
this? Can you read this for me in the
Huffs version?
>> Yep. The HS version says
so the word that is in question is which
means you are amazed or surprised.
>> You are amazed. Now who's the speaker
Jai in this context in chapter 37:12?
Who's the one speaking?
>> This is Allah speaking to Muhammad.
>> So Allah speaking to Muhammad and he
says you were surprised while they
mocked or you were amazed while they
mocked. Allah speaking to Muhammad. But
when we scroll down here and we see all
these different, you know, readings of
the Quran here, they're mostly the same.
But we get down to Alasai and Al Hamza.
We get here, what does it say here, DLC?
>> It says,
now tell us what the difference is.
>> What's happening here is Allah speaking
again, but he changes the pronoun. He
says,
that's the word difference. If you
remember in the habs was now what's the
difference here it says I was amazed.
>> Wow.
>> So Allah is amazed. Now before it was
Muhammad who was amazed.
>> So here's the big difference where we
got Allah who is the speaker. He's the
speaker in both ver in both versions of
the Quran. He's the speaker. And yet we
have Allah saying in one version he says
you were surprised while they mocked.
while in the other one here he says I
was surprised while they mobbed. So the
Muslims can't say oh well you know this
dialects and you know they all carry the
same meaning. No the meaning literally
like it changes the entire context. Was
it Muhammad who was surprised or was it
Allah who was surprised? Now if you want
to say both and then you know by all
means Allah say both. Both Allah and
Muhammad were surprised, but you can't
say that this isn't a difference and
that doesn't change the meaning. All
right, guys. So, that was chapter 37:12.
Have that in your bag. Easy variant to
show a Muslim. And we got another one.
So, that's number one. Number two, we
got Surah 10 verse 16. Now, J, go ahead
and talk to us about this. What's this
one about?
>> Okay, here is one that is a
contradiction. A lot of times, Muslims
will ask you, "Okay, show me where they
contradict." All right, here's where
they contradict. Chapter 10 verse 16
says, "Say, if Allah ws, I would not
have recited it to you, nor
would he have made it known to you." Nor
would he have made it known to you.
>> Now, if we look into the Arabic here,
>> okay, so that's the that's where we want
you to look. He would not have made it
known to you.
That's where the elongated sound it
means no not known to you. He would not
have made it known to you. That's what
most Muslims know about.
>> And then we go to one of readers and he
says
no elongated a anything. It's very short
which means he would have made it known
to you.
>> Oh wow. Those are two contradictions.
One says he would not have made it known
to you. The other one says he would have
made it known to you. There's there's no
way out of this one. This was this a
clear contradiction. That's clearcut.
>> But don't take our word for it. They
talk about it in the Muslim sources like
in here which is available online to
everyone. It does admit this variant
reading as you see here in the
highlighted versions. One says nor would
he have made it known and the other says
he would have made it known.
>> Wow. Yeah. There's no way out of this.
So even their scholars are seeing and
admitting that this is a contradiction.
So you can go on altapsere.com pull up
Jalain's taps and you can see it for
yourself and show the Muslims that even
their scholars are acknowledging that
this 010 verse 16 has a variant reading
that contradicts. So now if they're
asking for variance with contradictions,
we have those. If they're asking for
variants that show a change in meaning,
we have those. So these are two. We got
Sarah 37:12. We got chapter 10 verse 16.
Here's a third variant that you should
have in your pocket as a Christian. You
should be able to show this to a Muslim.
Go ahead, J. Talk to us. Walk us through
this.
>> This one is a legal variant. What do I
mean by that? I mean that depending on
which version of the Quran you're
reading changes and affects how you
practice the religion of Islam.
>> So the verse here is about how you
redeem a missed fast. So when Muslims
miss fasts in Ramadan, they have to make
them up. In surah 2 verse84 it says
means the redemption means the feeding
of
is the word here that you need which we
transliterated here one poor person
singular ms one poor person that's hs so
for every missed fast you have to feed
one poor person
>> however in the other version famous
version actually called it says fyaton
is the word here. So here the redemption
is by feeding plural people and in the
Arabic here the plural is more than two
>> three or more. Okay. So if you're living
in a part of the world that reads the
hquran if you miss a fast you have to
feed one person per missed fast. If you
are in a part of the world that reads
the Quran, for every missed fast, you
have to feed three or more poor people.
>> So, what you going to do?
>> That's tough. I uh Allah, I probably
have to say on that one, Allah knows
best. That That's tough. So, for every
fast day that I miss, depending on the
Quran that I'm reading, depending on the
Quran that I take authoritative, it
determines how I make up that fast day.
Now, the reason why this is so bad is
because if I do this wrong, then I'm not
purified before Allah. Is that right?
>> Correct. These fasts are obligation.
They're obligatory. They're not
voluntary, which means that's why they
don't go away if you miss them. Even if
you're ill, you can't fast that day. You
have to make it up. So, the rules of
Allah, what did Allah have in his mind?
Was he particularly generous that day
and said, "Just feed one person per mist
fast." or was he really strict about it
and said actually it needs to be three
or more per fast.
>> Wow.
>> It couldn't have been both. Which one
was in the mind of Allah when he
revealed that verse?
>> Wow. And I see that you got Alabari
there. What's what's Alab talking about?
>> So Alab here acknowledges that there's
the singular reading and then he also
acknowledges that there are others who
read it in the plural poor people. So ms
a poor person
poor people. So that's acknowledged by
Muslim commentators as well and by
Muslim jurists.
>> Wow. So not only do we have variants
that change the meaning, variants that
contradict, but we also have variants
that change the ruling how you are to
practice Islam and even purify
yourselves, make yourself right,
reconcile yourself back with Allah. If
you miss a fast day, do you just feed a
poor person and you're good to go? or do
you have to feed multiple poor people
and then you're good to go? So, that's
three down. We got two more to go. We
have a fourth Quran variant that you
guys should know. We're giving you guys
a list of five variants that every
Christian should know. Here's number
four. Now, what we got here, 90.
What we talking about here? Chapter
12:9. And what we have here is from the
Bridges translation, Fullman's
translation of the Quran, where he
actually notes in English some of the
variant readings. So chapter 12 verse 90
the brothers of Joseph think that they
see him in one version and they know
that they see him in another version. So
in one version of the Quran it says they
said can it be that you are really
Joseph? Can it be that you're really
Joseph? They don't know but if you see
on the bottom here in the footnote he
notes that there is Iba and Jaffer who
read it as they said you really are
Joseph. He even put an exclamation mark
like there an emphasis there.
>> Yeah. So, one reading they're not sure.
Could it be that you're Joseph? Are you
really Joseph? Is that you? We don't
know. And then the other reading they're
certain that that is really Joseph.
>> Wow. So, we got uncertainty in one
reading of the Quran. We got certainty
in in the other. And these both can't be
cuz these are the same this is the same
conversation, same instant, right? The
same uh scenario. This isn't both have,
you know, two different scenarios. This
is the same exact conversation being had
and it's being rendered differently in
the different Qurans. Is that right?
>> Exactly. And it's not some brothers said
this and some brothers said that. No, it
just says they said. So if you're
reading one version, you're going to get
the indication that they plural that
they said. Can it be you? Is that really
you? They don't know. Then the other
version makes you think that no, they
know for sure that it's him.
>> Right?
>> So it's not broken into different groups
or anything like that. Those excuses
don't work.
>> That's good. We've got the who speaks
about this and in the Arabic the Quran
has it in the question mark where they
say
which means are you
and he says in the in the different in
the other versions it it's confirmation
it's it's affirmative
you are Ysef
>> and actually prefers the question mark
one
>> so wait a second you have alabar
picking one reading of the Quran over
the other one.
>> Yes. Right here it says
he says
which means the correct reading. He says
according to us
which means the reading of one who
questions the one with a question.
>> Hold on a second. Let's just get this
straight. You mean to tell me daughter
of Christ, woman of God, that we have an
Islamic scholar, historian, right, one
of their best, one of their biggest is
saying that one of the readings of the
eternal Quran, the eternal speech of
Allah is incorrect.
>> He's saying the correct one is this,
>> which means the other is incorrect.
>> Exactly.
>> Because if it's both Allah, number one,
it can't be because what did did Allah
say? Okay, take two redo scene with
different line. Can't do that. What
happened historically is one thing and
if it was both he if he felt if he felt
that he respected both he wouldn't say
one is correct.
>> That means the other is incorrect.
>> So the same theory the same narrative
that we usually get from these Muslims
that all of these Qurans even though
these are different dialects and even
though there can be varants they're all
equally the same. They're all equally
correct and from Allah. This narrative
is squashed. It's a myth.
>> Exactly. The early Muslims like did not
believe that.
>> And nowhere did the said that this is
dialect. He said one is a question and
the other one is uh
>> affirmation.
>> Amen. Wow. That's awesome. Now with this
variant guys, it's a good response to
when Muslims say that uh you know the
the the the variant readings just have
to do with dialect and just how you know
certain Muslims and certain people
around the world uh pronounce certain
words and enunciate certain words and
you know they have a different way of
speaking but it's the same word it's the
same script right it has the same
skeleton and everything like that now
but this with this variant this doesn't
work if words are actually missing
Right. Giant DLC.
>> Exactly. How does that work? One Quran
has a word the other Quran doesn't have
or the other Quran has a word the other
one doesn't have. I thought they were
all the same.
>> They're supposed to all be the same,
man. Just just sound different.
>> That's what they say.
>> It tells me a scribe was sleepy.
>> Sleepy scribe.
>> The sleepy scribe.
>> So this is it. Chapter 57:4.
>> It says those who are stingy and enjoin
upon people stinginess. And whoever
turns away then indeed Allah is the free
of need the praiseworthy. So the bit
that we want to focus on is the Allah
free of need and praiseworthy which in
the Arabic it says
and the part is the problem
>> because we see it in some versions of
the Quran like huffs but it seems to
disappear in other versions of the Quran
like
>> so means he is. So in this version
there's no he is which messes up the
grammar. There's no is. So what we going
to do about this one? So what happened
here?
>> Now this is interesting. Just really
quick guys. So you can't pronounce a
word that is not there. Right.
>> Right.
>> You can't have a you can't have a
specific dialect on a word that doesn't
exist in the text.
>> Exactly.
>> Wow. This is a this is beautiful.
>> Yeah. So it's not just an accent or it's
not just a dialect. No, this is a
completely missing word. Or if you take
as the standard version of the Quran,
you could say that Huffs and other
versions added word.
>> Depends on which Quran is your Quran,
man.
>> Right.
>> Oh, that's good.
>> So we we'll just read we'll read them so
you guys can hear the difference. But
the key thing that you're want to be
listening for is the word who one of
them has the word who he is and the
other one doesn't have it at all.
>> Okay? So the one which has it says
and the one that doesn't have it says
no.
>> So basically it's like you know those
find the difference puzzles. It's the
same the same. Oh difference.
>> Where's the difference? Yeah, you can
see it with the eye even.
>> Wow. Yeah, you can literally see it with
your own eyes that a a word is gone from
the text or a word is added to the text.
You can clearly see it. So, so there you
guys have it. Five Quran variants that
every Christian should have in their
back pocket. We got chapter 37:12.
We got chapter 10:16, chapter 2 verse
184, chapter 12:90 and chapter 57 verse
24. Depending on which Quran is your
authoritative Quran, depending on which
Quran you got is going to be how you're
going to see these verses and how you're
going to deal with these verses. And
this is huge. This is huge because this
demonstrates again once and for all that
the standard narrative that the Quran is
perfectly preserved right down to the
letter. No difference in changes in the
meaning, no difference in context. All
of the words are preserved. This
standard narrative got them hoes, man.
[Music]
Oh my god. Logic.